Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie! So new Captain
America Civil War behind-the-scenes footage
let's talk a little bit about what's going
on with Black Panther in the movie the actually
gave us a little bit of a tease but we have
a pretty good idea. So the way the Russo's
are talking about Black Panther in this movie
make it sound like he has almost nothing to
do with what's going on between Captain America
and Iron Man that the Sokovia accords the
big line in the sand that's drawn. It's a
little more helpful if you think about it
in the context of comic book Civil War it's
really like a gun control issue. Tony Stark
wants gun-control so he wants to issue all
these regulations Captain America's all about
civil liberties so that's where they draw
the line in the sand in this movie it sounds
like Black Panther isn't in on any of that.
Why then is he kicking the shit out of winter
soldier in this trailer maybe his interest
in this matter is purely to track down winter
soldier now in the comics winter soldier has
killed a lot of people they they kind of address
that during the winter soldier movie you just
kind of see it in montage like he killed Kennedy
killed a bunch of important people in the
comics he also killed Tony Stark's parents
so maybe with the movies going to do is take
a little bit of that and give it to Black
Panther's character like you assassinated
my father so I'm going to come after you winter
soldier himself is kind of a tangential thing
in the movie because the governments of the
world sound like they're the ones that draft
these Sokovia accords like look we don't want
avengers or even villains for that matter
going out unchecked we like to make sure that
everyone is accountable to someone else so
really accountability is the issue here like
who do the avengers answer to if they are
the ultimate power in the world you can kinda
see the darkest timeline version of this work
it's in the watchmen territory like that that
the cynical version of this the Black Panther
just based on the footage we've seen of them
in the trailer so far looks like he is on
par with Captain America in terms of abilities
now Black Panther himself is just born a normal
human being his powers mostly flow from the
panther totem and the special herbs that he
eats he's also wearing a Vibranium Suit so
I'm assuming there's some tech involved in
there too Wakanda is one of the most advanced
rich nations in the world monetarily rich
that is is because of Vibranium him so how
ever you want to explain it, you could just
explain it with vibranium suit like he's wearing
a special suit makes him super powerful but
in the comics it goes a little bit deeper
than that there are mystical aspects to his
abilities but in terms of fighting ability
in this movie looks like he's about on par
with Captain America and winter soldier that's
kind of the point of the movie you know making
sure that everyone is evenly matched because
they're all friends fighting with each other
they don't want you to have a clear favorite
even though it's Captain America's movie is
probably going to be the one you walk away
with identifying the most speaking of fighting
abilities what about scarlet which envisioned
because they did say your scarlet which very
much more in command of her abilities in this
movie but she has a much more emotional arc
so I'm guessing that's going to be her Achilles'
heel like they balance all the characters
in some way like Holt can't control his abilities
so yet he could be superpowerful if he had
the mind of banner when he was the whole black
widow very capable amazing fighter but doesn't
have the year that the other people have so
she's not quite as strong as everybody has
their own weaknesses the kinda help balance
that out vision is the real? Though I'm curious
to see why he hasn't appeared in any of these
trailers they probably had a hard time keeping
him from turning to the Deus Ex Machina character
because he wields one of the infinity stones
and he has no loyalties to any of the characters
over other characters getting the ideas that
he is the most objective character possible
like he's probably bemused with the idea of
all these internal politics that are going
on the earth. That's a good question for you
guys let me know in the comments what do you
think that vision is going to be doing in
this movie is it sounds like he's gonna wind
up being team Iron Man so what is going to
happen to keep him from just shutting everyone
down at the same time because he's more powerful
than anyone else so there has to be a really
compelling reason for him to not go out and
capture everyone else when they refuse to
sign the Sokovia accords but in related news
there is some new Doctor strange videos all
totally do a video for that tomorrow the very
first X-Men apocalypse trailer is also dropping
I have no idea when I think it's gonna come
in the morning saw this I'll probably end
up doing that video first be sure to subscribe
to get it if you want updates on when all
those videos are coming you can follow me
on twitter and Facebook their links for that
at the bottom the description so while you
wait for everything else to post you can click
here for my Captain America Civil War trailer
video and you can click here for my latest
Star Wars trailer. Probably the last big Star
Wars trailer before the actual movie comes
think you so much for watching, everybody
high five and I'll see you tonight!